you're 60 doesn't matter 252 please also
died for you doesn't matter you're old
you know no now hold on you look the
same no matter what you do what you do
yeah but when I get my lids tucked and I
get on the old test I can do any of that
do that how long I'm gonna do it as soon
as I feel a little lagging my energy but
daddy's got a lot of energy daddy keeps
going daddy does daddy God did hurt his
shoulders a little bit again so injured
all cuz I box without warming up and
then I get in my car and I don't warm
down and I and and the trainer who
trains a lot of pro athletes look to me
it goes like this always 7c go he goes
just starting the box again huh no
warmup at all as usual just getting in
there huh just kind of thinking like
that I was like this guy knows something
I don't
I was like yeah you know I just started
slow no I don't well caught up to daddy
at 52 the old shoulder polders got
painful huh just tight huh now I got
pain here in this area between my
clavicle and my traps so that air is all
bunched up where where I was like oh I'm
spasming what I can't move my shoulders
were hitting with a Wayne again I hit
with yeah yeah and then I'm trying to
spar and all dumb so now now here's the
thing here's the thing I I took I took
some anti-inflammatories this is gonna
be surprising to you that I resist that
stuff let's do that night I took three
[ __ ] Advil all went away I'm like
trying to do all my stretches never take
it now
I took three advil I'm like oh this is a
this is a miracle it's all gone oh dude
I stay three weeks I was hurtin I stay
about 800 milligrams ibuprofen every day
cuz my foot that plantar fasciitis yeah
no Punk it just will not go away oh
really now sale so it's been here for
how long have I been talked about six
months so long sever had it put hiking
on Thursday or I was hiking on Friday
yeah just won't won't go and you but you
take the anti-inflammatories every day
that's all I do then I rolled it out
last night on like a ice block well at
the end you get that shot in the heel
yeah the cortisone what are you supposed
to do with this [ __ ] what do we know you
know what uses like stretches and [ __ ]
you can do look come on Rogan and my
buddy Joe janym or both of whom did the
stems
like the real one the cold and stem cell
cost you a fortune my buddy Joe Jana
more said and he's a hard-nosed guy he's
I don't know what's gonna happen I'll
try it his shoulders have hurt for 10
years not a pain in his shoulders and he
hasn't had a cold in 12 months I mean
and all the other things and Rogan said
that his the MRI he had a torn meniscus
after the stem cells the tears gone hmm
so there might be some real [ __ ] to this
I could put in my well you just inject
anywhere right yes so you get that much
maybe we got a Panama will we take a
boy's trip to Panama I had that offer
that guy had to go to Colombia though I
like you saw a ghost
well I had my head down us texting and I
just saw jeans and I was I thought it
was you I was gonna slap your ass really
hard cuz I thought you were like Ben no
his table yeah it was cat okay I would
write me at you
but he got a me-too movement that's
exactly right you would have been me to
it immediately
I know it's close that's to say
something to cat oh it boy we almost had
a problem almost slapped you right in
yeah you got a strong you got a strong
hand I'm really gonna slap at home too
cat what would you have done I think I
would have been in such shock for the
first couple seconds and just looking at
you like I would have been so
embarrassed Maya
but then waited like yeah Amanda who
doesn't know cars at all I had a black
BMW or something and she I was waiting
for her and I watch her come out of the
restaurant and she gets into a black SUV
and she's just sitting there
it's those yours yeah and I'm just
watching her as she's sitting in a black
SUV wait a minute come around and
finally she opens the door she goes and
I step out and she goes she's go up and
turn this what are you doing come on
let's go I go I said no ideas not your
car my car how would you confuse a
[ __ ] black SUV for a [ __ ] a
payment it yeah she just doesn't pay
attention to cars to that degree but
once a truck and ones who call correct
to that different stuff to that degree
be intelligent laughing yes [ __ ] I don't
know
Fred I mean I was like alright she did
it again
well this time jumped on a motorcycle no
this one go back in motor sound the cars
were a lot more similar and she got in
and sat down and the dude next to her I
went what are you doing in my car
that's buddy yeah but you guys ah and
ran out it is weird when you can lighten
up the mood I love this please do who
saw the CC
what is this anyways you guys don't know
he's a dancer it's just Bert [ __ ]
British great [ __ ] all right not only
athletic he's got a great golf swing and
he can dance he can dance a little why
are gonna work out together tomorrow
nice this is phenomenal by the way I
wish Burton her would a dance
side-by-sides where did he get tearaway
pants from in 2019 oh it's coming back
book-smart say what man I don't as far
as marketing Jean I don't know anyone
better than Bert genius that's great
there's no one better than Berta's
marketing and that great writer
yesterday I worked out with him at this
yeah class yeah should come to this hot
spin class with me he goes every day so
I walk in I had no idea what to expect I
walk in it's a it sounds like a giant
fart in there you have the heat blasting
this is in the valley it's called a
sweat shop yeah it's so hot I can't see
it's in the it's in the dark would like
some strobe lights Legionnaires disease
there we are
all I see is the light shine through
Bert's here and he's kind of losing this
hair psyche yeah like right that's Bert
so I sit down next to him and we're
going and like my eyes adjust to the
dark I'm like I like your Bert I go dude
where's all the chicks at yeah cuz why
don't you where's all the chicks Etta's
not here bro and then it's just him home
but I got an hour an hour Oh an hour us
doing work but but to the point Bert
does he's been super strict cuz he's
getting ready for silver October so he's
doing intermittent fasting he's working
out every single day and then he's like
the only funny goes you know I'm kind of
losing weight man I'm thinking you know
doing some stuff I'm gonna get shredded
I'm like yeah it'd be cool man they'll
be really cool and then he goes the only
problem is Wendy stand up man
few drinks and the [ __ ] Gila monster
comes out and I just [ __ ] right that's
all of us yeah you a mom decided to
leave New York I was the most successful
person in New York City and the
wealthiest I think that's a little I
don't know if I heard that Wow there's
no Brian no I know Vince
everybody not zomick's out there man
it's not true I was successful I had
surpassed Seinfeld laughs again Louie CK
Lois see Katella surpassed polo sighs
Norman I'd surpassed all of them yeah
and I was I was also the richest person
it makes sense I made more money than a
lot of the hedge fund guys I don't know
how you made that more than oh your
negativities you it doesn't eat meat you
know I'm just you know was it residuals
from it so once I got to the pinnacle of
New York where I literally owned New
York society about I had to get out to
come here and then take it over and I'm
halfway there halfway there you've been
here for how long uh three months you
came in like a tidal wave Oh but I
becoming a lot I've been coming out here
Elena now becoming in Enochs I just see
me story yeah I just started
I wide star but I've started working
there probably three months so adidas
has just signed a deal with pro great
pro gamer ninja neither can you tell
that man he's killing it but [ __ ] this
guy what's he like
he left twitch Rome a platform they paid
him how much maybe million 20 million
right now it was a really really big
deal he's a huge deal I don't respect
people that don't use their own name I
mean any extreme winner is probably the
same he'd be as an extreme winner I
watched his documentary on Kelly Slater
[ __ ] Samurai I know I'm late to the
party I know how much he's won but
Achilles slew but he's such a freak like
he's such a freak he's so good what yeah
I mean it's a Kelly Slater dude I mean
been a legend for it no I understand
that what advocating Michael Jordan
what's the same to Michael Dorris
surfing right so you're saying like
ninja we like you just a killer in any I
don't know these extreme runners who are
these outliers they have something to
them that I think you're a great surfer
I'm saying there's something about these
guys that makes them that good at a
gamer they have a different way they can
see things very
he is incredibly explainer has big
apparently really big feet he's
double-jointed he's got a weird body
right everything about his body fits
surfing yeah he's so far away [ __ ]
great yeah yeah he is the first
professional gamer to get a deal with a
shoe company he would get six to eight
million a year about twenty four million
twenty four million for three years
ah did you see momentum generation know
about about Kelly Slater and the group
that came up with house and they all
came from broken homes that's last year
yes last year and it's it's so worth
watching because I'll watch what can i
watch HBO the [ __ ] that these guys were
doing how they came up together and when
you're serving there the guy goes well
you you can be the king of your Beach if
you can't surf Hawaii you ain't [ __ ] Wow
and not only in Hawaii when you go there
the locals will beat the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of you if you're not I'll kill is
legitimate so now Hawaii's where you get
those crazy waves right dude sure and
they die how about that people get break
their net oh my god you get slammed into
the coral it's a great time well it well
good because I think there should be a
little risk wow this is a great [ __ ]
documentary I'm gonna check that out
yeah he's a slave hard man but I mean I
always knew that Slater was now liar but
then when they break this down on how
strategic and how competitive and and
how he just kept winning it's just it's
I'll always watch if surfing's on it
like a bar I'll always watch if I'm
eating or something me too all what
always watch sir fascinating yeah I love
watching it I love the guys on the wave
runners that are like another wave them
has a guy who's wild right it's an
interesting thing that I don't know
enough about and I'd like to watch a
documentary and learn about it then
forget everything I learned okay when I
watch a documentary I can't remember any
of it